chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett is with us major good morning
morning as ed mentioned Warren was
suddenly the target in the center of
everything last night how did she handle
being the front-runner with poise
passion and on medicare-for-all evasion
she's made a tactical decision that she
doesn't need to answer this tax question
that her supporters are gonna stick with
her and that she can ride this out is
that the right right we will find out
voters will tell us about this but she
had every opportunity last night to just
say what Bernie Sanders had said keep
the gap between them as narrow as
possible she didn't she's tactically
decided this is not gonna make or break
her campaign she's gonna stick with the
approach he's had historically which has
been very successful she is without a
doubt run the most disciplined and
effective campaign so far she has not
only taken over the progressive lane
she's become the most leading candidate
in this and you saw last night when
you're getting all the incoming yo you
know you're at the top of the heap this
was Joe Biden's first debate since
questions about his son's role mccrane
he's now kind of Co frontrunner did he
respond to the criticisms of his son's
behavior overseas effectively there was
a simple question put to the former vice
president last night you put out a
statement Sunday that no one in your
family if you were elected can be on any
boards if it's not okay with your
president why was it okay when you were
vice president he evaded that answer
just as conspicuously to my mind as
Elizabeth Warren evaded the question
about taxes for Medicare for all if he
thinks this question is gonna go away it
might be right for the primaries maybe
Democrats are not going to harangue him
on this I know someone who will the
president United States right you better
come up with an answer yeah well they
have time to come up with an answer for
sure Bernie Sanders certainly didn't
seem to evade anything this was the
first time we've seen him since his
heart attack and everybody was watching
people were supporting him can they walk
away saying Bernie still got it seen yes
I think so his performance last night
was solid and recognizable in every
sense no hint at all that he had had
this health scare and I think it's
interesting to note that these
endorsements will try to reset the
campaign put some new energy and life
into it in the sense that he got a OCS
endorsed yes which is interesting cos in
2016 he was not the candidate who sought
or thought endorsements were important
her name was Hillary Clinton but now
playing the endorsement because he needs
someone on the outside to say this
campaign is still viable and has energy
that's an important reset what about the
lower end of the of the candidate
spectrum the anyone stand out is so I've
said before here that I think
geographically positioned Amy Klobuchar
has the best opportunity to be that
alternative in Iowa if Democratic voters
are looking for an alternative she used
her time well last night effective
aggressive and also I think you got a
look at Andrew yang and P Buddha judge
again there were these deserts last
night where you were not on camera for
long stretch this debate desert when you
have 12 people he had in three hours
but people to judge and Andrew yang once
they got the mics used their time very
fair gonna need a wider angle on that
stage manager Garrett thank you very
much we'll see if any of this moves the
polls more spaying and neutering
[Laughter]